>> Greg: AS YOU KNOW,
HILLARY CLINTON IS ON HER PLEASE
DON'T FORGET ME TOUR.
YES, TRUMP IS HER MEAL TICKET,
HER FREE BIRD, HER STAIRWAY TO
HEAVEN.
SHE BROUGHT TO CHELSEA, AS SHE
IS ALSO UNEMPLOYED.
HER NAME IS CRYSTAL.
>> IF ANYONE SHOULD BE TELLING
TRUMP JOKES, IT'S ME.
50% OF TRUMP'S TWEETS HAVE BEEN
ATTACKS ON PEOPLE.
100% HAVE BEEN ATTACKS ON THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE.
IT CAME OUT TO A TOTAL OF 6,000
TWEETS ATTACKING PEOPLE, EVEN
MORE SURPRISING, ONLY 3,000 OF
THOSE WERE ABOUT MY EMAILS.
>> SEAN SPICER NOW IS ON
"DANCING WITH THE STARS."
IT IS AN IMPROVEMENT ON HIS OWN
JOB, DANCING AROUND THE ISSUE.
I CAN'T BLAME TRUMP FOR TRYING
TO HELP SEAN SPICER, BUT IF
THERE IS ONE THING WE'VE
LEARNED, IS THAT THESE GUYS
REALLY CAN'T WIN THE POPULAR
VOTE.
>> Greg: THOSE JOKES REALLY
KILLED SAYS THE GHOST OF JUST
DOMINIC JEFFREY EPSTEIN.
HE LETS YOU KNOW HE'S ALL RIGHT
BUT IS STILL DYING INSIDE.
YET, IT'S GOOD TO LAUGH, BUT
ALSO TO MOVE ON.
MAYBE THIS IS A NEW THING
THOUGH.
OPEN NIGHT FOR LOSERS.
AFTER HILLARY, INVITE JEFF.
FOUR YEARS AGO, YOU WERE GIVEN
TWO CHOICES.
TRUMP WINS AND HILLARY IS DOING
STAND-UP.
EVERY TIME HILLARY CRACKS A
JOKE, IT'S A REMINDER WHICH ONE
YOU GOT.
HILLARY IS WELCOME TO OVERSTAY
HER WELCOME.
IT'S FUN TO BE REMINDED THAT
TRUMPED AND IT JUST WIN.
HE PUT AN EXCLAMATION POINT
FINALLY AT THE END OF HER
SENTENCE.
HE KILLED THE DYNASTY.
ENJOY THE JOKES.
WHEN IT'S COMING FROM THE
CLINTONS.
THEY RIGHT THEMSELVES.
I LOVE HILLARY KENNEDY.
I NEVER WANTED HER TO LEAVE.
ASK ME HAPPY.
>> Kennedy: HER DAUGHTER HAS
THE CHARISMA OF A COLD BOWL OF
BLEACH.
IT'S REALLY AN ACT OF
DESPERATION.
AT THIS POINT, I KNOW HILLARY'S
FORMER SPOKESPERSON MADE THE
ROUNDS ON VARIOUS --
HE IS SAYING WHILE, THE IS NOT
CLOSED.
GO AHEAD AND RUN.
OTHERWISE, WHAT IS THIS EXACTLY?
BECAUSE IT'S NOT NECESSARY FOR
THE POLITICAL CONVERSATION.
SHE'S NOT TALKING ABOUT ANY
IDEAS.
>> Greg: IT WELL, SHE HAS A
BOOK OUT.
>> Jesse: SHE IS WORKING TO
PROMOTE THE BOOK THAN SHE DID TO
PROMOTE
WHOMOTE
WHENOTE
WHEN TE
WHEN THE WHITE HOUSE.
SHE WANTS TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY ARE TRYING TO GROOM HER TO
BE A POLITICAL FIGURE.
THE GROOMING IS NOT GOING VERY
WELL.
I MEAN, SHE CAN'T DELIVER A JOKE
EVEN IF THE JOKES WERE WRITTEN
FOR HER.
DOES SHE MAKE MONEY AT THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION?
AGAIN, I'M NOT GOING TO GO
THERE.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT TAKES A
LOT OF TIME.
CHELSEA NEEDS A STEP UP AND SHE
REACHED DOWN, SHE GRABBED
CHELSEA, AND THEY ARE TRYING TO
HELP CHELSEA OUT A LITTLE BIT.
SEE TO IT I GET BEING OBSESSED
WITH WINNING, BUT BEING OBSESSED
WITH WINNING THIS KIND OF SAD.
I FEEL BAD FOR HER WHILE I'M
ENJOYING IT.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU ARE
I THINK IN FACT, IT'S
REPUBLICANS WHO DELIGHT IN
TORMENTING AND HOLDING HER UP.
HE ASKED HER TO DO THAT SHOW.
I'M SAYING, HANG ON, KENNEDY.
SHE GETS AN AUDIENCE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SEE
HER.
POLITICALLY, GUESS WHAT, SHE IS
MAKING AN IMPORTANT POINT FOR
DEMOCRATS, WHICH IS PAY
ATTENTION TO THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
SHE'S BEEN MAKING THAT POINT.
DON'T LOSE YOUR FOCUS.
YOU'VE GOT TO FOCUS ON THE SWING
STATES, THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE,
IF YOU'RE SERIOUS ABOUT BEATING
TRUMP.
>> Dana: EXACTLY.
THAT'S A GREAT LESSON.
THANKS TO TAKE AWAY FROM YOUR
LOSS, PAY ATTENTION TO THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
ALSO, SOMEBODY MUST BE TELLING
THEM THAT THEY ARE DOING GREAT.
I WAS SO FUNNY.
I WAS DYING.
I HAD TO REMIND IT.
SO FUNNY.
>> Juan: GOOD FRIENDS TELL YOU
WHEN YOU ARE BOMBING.
>> Jesse: WELL, I MEAN BILL'S
HAPPY.
>> Kennedy: THAT'S WHY SHE
LOST, BECAUSE SHE HAS PEOPLE
AROUND HER WHO WON IT TELL HER,
"YOU ARE DOING THE WRONG THING."
IT WAS VERY CLEAR FROM 2015 ON
THAT PEOPLE CLING TO GIVE A
SENSE OF WHO SHE REALLY WAS.
SHE WAS GIVING THE WRONG SPEECH,
SHE WAS FOCUSING ON THE WRONG
ISSUES.
SHE TOOK SO MUCH FOR GRANTED,
BECAUSE SHE HAS SO MANY FANS
AROUND HER BLOWING AIR UPPER --
>> Juan: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
HILLARY HAS FANS IN THE AIR OF
DONALD TRUMP?
HOLY SMOKES.
>> Kennedy: I'M NOT GOING TO
USE UNSAVORY LANGUAGE TO FULFILL
YOUR --
ANYONE WHO CAN'T LET GO OF A
PRESIDENTIAL LOSS, IT'S
PATHOLOGICAL.
>> Juan: TRUMP HAS THE SAME
EMAIL PROBLEM.